well today I wanted to talk about a
property of functional programming
called immutability and how immutability
it helps affect concurrency models and
you know the advantages and
disadvantages of having immutable States
you know so they should be used in some
areas and not used in others if you
remember you when you were back in
school they used to go in and teach you
the equations say Y is equal to x
squared minus 1 you did your calculation
and then you figured out what Y was and
that worked fine until you started
teaching you to program all of a sudden
when they were teaching you to program
what you got was X is equal to x squared
minus 1 and all of a sudden they
introduced mutability into the whole
equation where you had values but then
you went in and changed the values this
started causing kind of confusion
because it's wrong it kind of defies the
laws of mathematics this is wrong you
know it shouldn't be that way even when
you program you you should have you know
Y is equal to x squared minus 1 and this
is your an example of an immutable state
so that's the idea if something can
change right so X is something and then
it can become something else that is
correct so mutability what you do is you
change some parts of it and you retain
it some common bits so you know that's
mutability you basically the value
changes or some parts of that value
change immutability basically you share
what you can and copy what you can't
that's a way of seeing it let's look at
how the immutability mutability affect
your concurrency models concurrency
oriented programming is when you have
processes as your main building block of
your system and concurrence itself you
know what you do is you they don't have
to run at the same time but you model it
that way so they could in theory be
running at the same time and it's an
easier way to reason and an easier way
to code and program and and this goes in
contrast to parallelism where you
actually have processes which are
running at the same time so see it as a
subset you know cici concurrency as
subset of parallelism so there are two
ways of you know doing concurrency one
is based on mutable state where we've
got processes and processes usually
threads when it comes to mutable state
we'll go in and share memory so that
means any thread you know which has
access so the shared memory can go in
and edit it and this is where you
program with locks you program with
semaphores and the likes and then you've
got notion memory so you've got
concurrency models with immutable state
and in those cases you've got processes
and processes do not share memory but
they communicate with each other through
message passing so they communicate with
each other by copying the data from one
process to the other and so now they'll
each have their own copy and you know
they're able to do whatever they want
with it so you know the only entity the
only item which is that allowed to
mutate the process state is the process
itself if we're dealing with a mutable
state you've got a thread or a process
running in a critical section so
basically writing to the shared memory
what happens if something goes wrong so
what happens if the process terminates
what you didn't need to do is you need
to go in and terminate all of the
threads which have access to the shared
memory because you do not know your what
state the process which terminated left
at shared memory and it could
potentially be corrupt
so you basically lose everything in
there in a mutable state what happens if
a process you know state gets corrupted
or crashes or something goes wrong with
it is that you just lose the state of
that particular process which was
corrupt in the first place all other
processes are not affected by it because
you know they'll have their own copy of
the data hopefully not corrupted and you
know continue executing so it's a way of
isolating failure your second problem
with mutable state is you know where do
you locate your data you've got shared
memory where do you locate it so you've
got a process running in Nottingham and
you've got one process running in London
and they need to share memory where do
you place your shared memory becomes a
bit hard versus immutable state where
you've got not
and you've got London you don't share
memory you copy the state so they'll
each have their own copy of the data and
you can execute without so so show
you're avoiding problems of locality
here assume you figure out with your
mutable state between Nottingham and
London you'll praise your shared memory
in Leicester what happens all of a
sudden when the network goes down
between them you know because here in
the middle you've got your share data
all of a sudden you can't accept it
there's one thing here you need to be
aware when you're programming in life
they're free certainties one is taxes
death and network partitions so you can
be sure that you know if you've got a
network something will go wrong with it
versus immutable state you've got a copy
Nottingham you've got a copy in London
so even if the network goes down they'll
each have their own copy of the data to
continue running and what you need to do
is when the network does come back up
you will have to go in and synchronize
the data again and you know there are
many tools distributed databases and
techniques to do that it's very clear
that if you're dealing mutable state the
mutability will work but it will work
only if you're running your friends on a
single machine so without a network and
assuming nothing goes wrong and you know
many many use cases where you need that
approach especially those use cases
where copying memory is not efficient
you know where your computations have be
extremely fast so it's not a question of
you know one or the other it's it's a
question of very much of using the right
tool for the job and yeah it's not
always mutable state and it's not always
immutable state you know these are these
are the science decisions you need to
make when you go along some examples of
where you might choose a mutable state
most likely I mean you would use mutable
state where say in the finance base
where you're doing algorithmic trading
computation time is critical and complex
as well where if something crashes and
go wrong you just don't do the trade but
if you do get your results you need to
be fast and you you know get you know
execute that trade as quickly as
possible as an example or your rendering
of graphics for example or you know
where you might want to split it up but
you know do do as much as you want as
much as possible in parallel so son
critical bison time critical
applications absolutely which can run on
a single machine and don't need to be
distributed so let's step back a second
you have been using the terms mutable
state and immutable state you probably
recognize them with the notion memory
approach versus the shared memory
approach and I think a very common your
shared memory approach is for example
Java which is breads and friends will go
in a shared memory and what I'm seeing
happening a lot out there though is
applying techniques from immutable state
to process and threads with mutable
state so what happens is that you only
allow the Fred you know which owns the
data to go in and mutate it and you know
and and that resolves and addresses a
lot of the issues we've discussed now so
you know it's again you're very much the
right tool for the job so if you look at
modern architectures today I mean
everything from embedded devices to
supercomputers they are based on your
heterogeneous multi-core architectures
and most of them are your by nature
distributed so you know think you know
what we've been looking at today is
basically the future of programming you
know future programming languages will
be concurrent they have to be concurrent
and they'll have a concurrency model
based on a mutable state so you know
immutable state you know being one of
the properties they've inherited from
functional programming languages you
might not be using functional
programming languages on a day to day
basis but using your the paradigms and
the principles and adopting them with
your mains know your mainstream
technologies will make you much better
programmer and they'll make you much
more efficient and productive anyone we
mentioned though the immutability there
was a speed penalty right so how do we
address that so we'll the mutability
indeed you have a speed penalty but you
know the speed penalty becomes even more
serious when you start looking at
Amdahl's law every one and a half years
until you know the mid-2000s chips we're
getting you know
becoming twice as fast then and those
law you know because of and also they've
hit the limit and now you need to deal
you know you gain speed through
multi-core and we with multi-core
programming you need a different
approach and what you do is you start
paralyzing your computations so you know
desktops will very soon have 64 cores
you know we'll be seeing machines with
million cores you know within our
lifetimes you know you start utilize
instead of you're making one a
single-threaded program which runs
extremely fast you now start paralyzing
your programs and so you start breaking
up your computations into many smaller
computations and this you know the only
way to do that is concurrently
programming with a mutable state with a
concurrency model based on a mutable
state
yeah that you seem to have yeah you see
it's been hung by your own what is it
got busted yes